and by the way Joe
um the Mexican president is now boasting
that his country is safer than the U.S
apparently everyone on earth now knows
that they can walk all over Joe Biden
and they know that most cities and towns
have adopted this defund dismantle no
bail law Insanity of the Democratic
Socialist Party here with reaction South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham is with
a senator a lot to a lot to talk about
tonight
they shot down our drone what should our
answer be
well we should hold them accountable and
say that if you ever get near another
U.S set flying in international waters
your airplane would be shot down what
would Ronald Reagan do right now he
would he would start shooting Russian
planes down if they were threatening our
assets American foreign policies and
Free Fall I can't add much to what
you've said all I can tell you is that
on multiple fronts we're in a dangerous
situation weakness breeds provocation
the Spy balloon over the United States
shooting down an American drone
multi-million dollar drone they know
they can get away with it Mexico is
blaming us for the fentanyl crisis and
Joe Biden is like a deer in the
headlights he needs to up his game
quickly okay now to what extent do you
believe Joe's lack of reaction to the
Chinese spy balloon and the fact Russia
was watching the trip over Alaska the
trip down the coast to Canada the trip
into Idaho Montana Kansas Missouri
Kentucky and then they made it to your
great state of South Carolina and then
finally shot it got shot down uh well
obviously Putin was watching all this
President XI was testing us God only
knows what these lasers are in Hawaii do
you have any insight into what they are
no but it all started with uh
Afghanistan when Biden got into Power he
pulled out of Afghanistan and that said
everything else in motion uh Obama's
President Putin invades uh Ukraine takes
Crimea Biden gets elected President
Putin's trying to dismantle Ukraine the
border is completely broken the Mexican
president is taunting the United States
belittling the Republican Party claiming
Mexico is not responsible for the
poisoning of America through Fentanyl
and our commander-in-chief is sitting
around playing the fiddle while the
world Burns so President Biden you're
the Rodney Dangerfield of world leaders
nobody respects you and if you don't
change your game and up your game we're
going to have World War III here's the
next War that's coming Israel is going
to have to take military action to stop
the Iranians from developing enriched
uranium to the point it can become a
weapon they're at 84 percent all they
have to do is get to 90 percent we're
not doing a damn thing about the
Iranians trying to develop a nuclear
bomb under our plain sight I would like
to know we know that Russian drones are
flying over Ukraine yeah why don't we
shoot down two of theirs and send a
message you shoot down one of ours we'll
shoot down to the first time 10 the next
time why don't we do it now and send a
Rea do it now
well what did what did Trump do when the
Iranians were killing Americans all over
the Mideast he killed solomonia right
what did he do to take down the
caliphate he unleashed the military and
the caliphate was destroyed in about
three months do you believe for one
minute that Russia would have done this
on Trump's watch Do You Believe for one
minute that Russia would have invaded
Ukraine if Donald Trump
I think they had a healthy realistic
fear of Donald Trump
there is no fear of Joe Biden his
policies are not working or being walked
on we're being crapped on and we're
about to have a major war because China
is sizing up Biden and they're going to
go into Taiwan if we don't upper game in
Ukraine Biden's always late to the game
Senator mark my words he wouldn't lift a
finger last question and I talked to a
lot of my conservative friends and they
they they generally know the Putin is
evil they know Russia is a hostile
regime they openly supported you know
financial support Joe Biden has
steadfastly uh not permitted the
ukrainians to get fighter jets migs from
Poland and other countries also Western
European countries have not paid their
fair share and he's not fighting to win
if he's not going to allow zielinski to
have the Mig jets that poll and offer
them so if they're not going to fight
and win I really can't blame Americans
saying then why are we even bothering
helping at all and if Western Europe
isn't going to do their part why should
we Penny up anything
stay tuned my friend we're gonna we're
gonna come down hard on France and
Germany who are not doing enough to help
Ukraine is in their backyard okay number
one if Putin gets away with this there
goes Taiwan the two are connected so the
administration the Biden Administration
it's been slow and weak every time
Ukraine needs a weapon system we have to
beg to get it so I'm all in to win it
and you're not going to win this war by
bleeding Ukraine dry and giving them
weapons they need too late to affect the
outcome on the battlefield so Joe
Biden's a disaster on the foreign policy
front we're in freeze Hall I've never
been more worried about world stability
than I am right now we're on the verge
of major conflict with China you forgot
one
we're getting lectured by Mexico that
they are a safe account yeah but we'll
save that for another day Senator thank
you appreciate it thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else